historique puisque pour la première fois
vous m'entendez bien pour la première
fois des huit en direct va maintenant
célébrer les animateurs les plus
antipathiques
diriger cette cérémonie je ne vais pas
le faire seuls les trois premiers nommés
seront là dans quelques instants
mais pour remettre ce prix je tenais à
avoir quelqu'un d'emblématique car c'est
lui qui dirige l'association des
animateurs antipathique depuis des
années maintenant
il a été lui-même j'appelle le grand
nelson monfort qui est avec nous
merci
meehan une première question en tant que
président vous même des animateurs
antipodiques en deux heures qu'est ce
que représente ce trophée ça change une
carrière quand même alors je crois que
c'est l'aboutissement de resina batteur
c'est l'aboutissement de toute carrière
je suis très heureux de présider cette
association je pense ne va cesser de
grandir surtout surtout après qu'on vous
aura annoncé les trois lauréats de ce
soir sur lesquels il y à vraiment des
surprises mais je pense que nous serons
en bonne compagnie mon cher julien parce
que vous avez oublié de dire également
que vous étiez le vice présidente c'est
assez cher évidemment avec les
chroniqueurs avec une onde bien sûr
l'émotion est palpable
il est grand temps d'appeler le premier
celui qui est classé numéro 3 dont on
peut rappeler le palmarès des saumons
soir extraordinaire son palmarès est
tout à fait impressionnant puisque on ne
compte pas le nombre de chaînes sur
lesquelles il a travaillé pour la chine
le nombre de chaînes sur lesquelles il
n'a pas travaillé qu'ils sont beaucoup
moins nombreuses
donc il a successivement travaillé sur
m6 sur tf1 sur d8 il hérisse le poil et
stings 13% des français s'est dit très
bien qu'il est très aimé par 87% des
français ce qui n'est rien de dire
nelson qu'on comprend mieux que vous
soyez présidents d'associations quand on
vous en tant que malade ou même
d'appeler maintenant qu'à vous le savez
nous sommes en direct charge et il faut
appeler le numéro 3 qui est autre que
jamais
malheureusement pas pu être avec nous ce
soir
b
c'est mon père
savez vous vous appuyez sur la place du
meurtre ou alors ça doit être quand même
terriblement émouvant pour un père
d'avoir un fils consacré comme étant
l'un des animateurs les les plus
détestés en france quelle est votre
première impression
je suis très déçu qu'il ne soit que
troisième mais très déçu mais j'ai fait
ma faute c'est mal élevé j'ai appris à
dire au revoir merci
j'aurais dû lui dire d'envoyer balader
tout le monde aurait peut-être les
premiers ce serait autant qu être
antipathique autant est le 1er mai ce
que c'est fou est ce que dans la famille
des gens lui inculquer ces valeurs là
tout petit de tout petits c'était très
élevé à la brutale mise hier jean-pierre
public want to know you taste of band
jamais il concevait pas de punitions
corporelles
on me signale qu'il faut passer au
deuxième exposé je veux le savoir du mal
à la roue de laisser le soin à la
deuxième place oui c'était une
phénoménale surprise puisqu'il hérisse
le poil il angoisse plus de 17% des le
génome c'est une cité à sévérac il ya 83
% des français qu'ils adorent ce qui
n'est rien n'est ce pas et c'est un
véritable professionnel de la tan assez
de lara sera les intéressés en
comprimant il s'agit de quelqu'un qui
débute un petit peu qu'ils aient pas
encore très connu dans ce studio s'était
fulgurant en quelques mots il a réussi à
agacer toute la france
c'est pour ça qu'il est là ce soir
monsieur cyril hanouna
c'est lui
s'il quelques mois pour tous ces gens
qui vous ont détesté que vous voulez
remercier maintenant c'est surtout ce
soir je suis à la fois heureux heureux
parce que je fais mon entrée dans le top
3 et c'est vrai que voilà j'espérais
faire mon entrée dans le top 3 depuis de
nombreuses années maintenant je suis
néanmoins déçu parce que là parce que je
voulais c'est la revoilà la place de
numéro un les prochains non non l'année
prochaine j'aurai voulu que ce soit
cette année le sait encore l'autre qu'il
a eue là on n'en révèle pas on le sait
mais il a eu voilà donc je sans doute
comme un bruit non je vais essayer de
faire tout ce que monfils l'a battu il
ya deux trois ans dames on avait quand
même pour battre le numéro 1 vous avez
de la concurrence je vais faire le
maximum
j'ai essayé de faire le maximum l'année
prochaine pour être encore plus lourd
voilà et je vais demander à thierry
moreau voilà deux de s'occuper de moi
pendant toute l'année dans la centre le
classement est très serré puisque ray
17% pour la médaille d'argent
médaille d'argent qui sera remis dans
quelques instants et 18% seulement pour
la médaille d'or donc il a été élu de
justesse l'animateur le plus
antipathique celui que 18% des français
ne peuvent pas souffrir sévir tiana 82
qu'il a dirigée de l'agacement les
enfants à la télé le décor pencher des
merveilles fait pour emmerder ceux qui
les regardent
il est là ce soir c'est le grand arthur
le numéraire
avant
sortie en salle et vous
merci
je crois que place à l'émotion arthur
tout de suite je vois votre sourire que
vous aviez envie de reconquérir cette
place quand vous aviez perdu faut dire
que ces dix dernières années j'ai été
huit fois premier et j'ai eu une petite
traversée du désert depuis deux ans
besoin j'ai eu un petit passage à vide
puisque l'année dernière ces droits je
crois qu'il y avait cette panne du
podium
voilà la question qu'on se pose quand on
perd sa première place comment fait-on
pas réveiller ont pu les basques être
antipathique c'est un boulot ça à
l'entraînement ça se pratique bajeux au
restaurant je laisse pas trop bois dans
les taxis je fais enlever un mc pour
mettre les pieds dans le plat c'est dire
que chez antipathique
qu'est ce que je fais j'ai un coup tu
vocale pour avoir une voie de mer dans
la télévision aux policiers
j'ai une très belle voix gilles super
belle voix mais je prends cette voie
pour est antipathique un peu plus de
torture ma dernière question oui ou non
rester numéro 1 s'est servie de jeu pour
en conserver santé veut vu mon mari j'ai
eu mon ascension
alors alors je m'adresse aux aux plus
jeunes d'entre vous la jeune génération
des animateurs je ne me laisserai pas
faire j'ai la niaque
je suis prêt à tout je suis prête ou par
exemple s'il le faut je suis prêt à
quitter la france pour aller vivre à
l'étranger mais pas dire si vous vivez
déjà en belgique
alors s'il le faut je suis prêt à
revenir peut-être remettre les médailles
je suis je suis muet die de bronze je
vais tout donner dans les prochaines
d'arrêter série gp2 de mettre la main
sur le coeur enfin médaille d'or
merci sûr je crois que nous allons
maintenant entendre l'hymne national
alors bravo les gars on va mettre
l'hymne national français tunisiens est
belle la france reconnaissante pour ces
trois emmerdeur fait entre la musique
elle est déjà derrière toi connard
deux morts
c'est pas une bonne idée cette fanfare
mais tu dois donner c'est tout lui est
sa coupe et la fanfare au mieux de la
marche et ça que tu prends des points
pour les prochaines ça c'est bien mais
les nouveaux combats méthode ou la
marseillais jamais c'est un coup bas
c'est un coup bas mais vrai qu'avec nous
reste à des peurs voilà
on
la tue
à lire les formats sanglante est le bel
le temps là
lover
entendez vous donne
c'est fait
ça l'a tué
ma
mais dans ce
citoyens
un macho
car
merci je suis
je sais que je sais que tu trépigne à
l'idée de prendre cette place pour l
année a causé deux vieux briscards sois
patient surtout arthur un cadeau je
crois parise
oui j'ai un cadeau pour toi oui ah ouais
ça c'est pousser à souvenirs de nos
d'année tournage de vendre et tout est
permis
limoux et de l'imodium
pas sûr
ça fait les gars à la jeune laure l
année prochaine je l'aurais là là là
c'est bon alors merci merci beaucoup les
chéris merci à toutes et ouais du doux
tout doux benhaim arthur merci à elle
avec panache un ça va
non mais j'en connais tu l'as fait chaud
bah oui non
[ __ ] merci jean pierre c'est du banc